GILBERT STRANG: Hi.
I'm Gilbert Strang.
I'm a math professor at MIT.
CLEVE MOLER: And
I'm Cleve Moler.
I'm one of the
founders of MathWorks,
and I'm chief mathematician.
Gil and I have
made a video series
about ordinary
differential equations.
GILBERT STRANG: This
developed really
from my experience of
the linear algebra class.
It's videotaped and
shown on OpenCourseWare.
And it was my first
time to discover
that millions of people
were learning, watching it.
And it just seemed
possible to tackle
the other major undergraduate
courses after calculus.
The other lead in to
engineering and science.
Differential equations with
the two sides of the formulas
and the computations.
CLEVE MOLER: This is not only
for students that are currently
in school, after calculus.
But it's also for
lifelong learners.
People who want to come
back to this material,
maybe after years out of school.
We want to help people who
are using MATLAB to solve
differential equations.
To understand the
MATLAB ODE suite.
To turn the black
boxes into grey boxes,
where you have
some understanding
of the mathematics
that underlies them.
GILBERT STRANG: Really,
differential equations
is the expression, the
mathematical expression
of change.
So engineering, finance,
economics, life sciences,
medical sciences where you're
seeing things change over time.
Those are modeled by
differential equations.
So we want to understand
what does solutions
look like for formulas?
And what do they look
like for numbers?
For actual quantities.
CLEVE MOLER: Gil and
I are matrix guys.
Our professional lives have
been involved with matrices.
And MATLAB started life
as Matrix Laboratory.
Here we are doing
differential equations.
Why is that?
That's because matrices are
fundamental in understanding
modern differential equations.
Systems of ordinary
differential equations
are the key to understanding
modern applications
of differential equations.
GILBERT STRANG: We
hope you enjoy it.